Hassan Ali collects plastic bottles from
this pile of garbage and Sanaa he has a
lot to choose from because a shortage of
fuel means the city's garbage is not
being moved out to landfills this has
become the only way for Hassan and
others to survive we are happy that this
place has become the main garbage
collection center we sell plastics for
three years dollars but it hardly covers
the needs of our family many of the
city's garbage trucks are parts of this
depart in the capital the man in charge
of operations here says at least two
tons of garbage are piling up every day
he's appealing to the international
community for help
nearly three hundred thousand liters of
diesel a month even in the current
crisis we won't be able to deliver our
services to the community if the crisis
persists trucks unload the garbage here
at this makeshift collection center this
is our first initiative to cut down
consumption fuel health experts are
warning of an unprecedented
environmental crisis that could trigger
another color
outbreak the recent one killed at least
3,000 people local and international
health officials warned this fuel and
garbage crisis could hamper their
efforts to eradicate cholera so far at
least 900 Yemenis have died from the
waterborne disease this year fuel crisis
is likely to undermine our efforts to
lower the case of cholera and other
epidemics the spread of garbage and
sewage water are the main reasons behind
the spread of such diseases the crisis
has not only affected garbage collection
it's also making it difficult for people
to move around the city public transport
is difficult to find hammer NASA used to
work as a driver for a private company
lost my job because the company owner
couldn't allocate diesel choose.you the
severe shortage
now I cannot even afford to refill my
gas cylinder as gas prices are high as
well life has become very difficult in
our country the healthy say despite
giving up control of ports including
perdida in the south and the last year's
Sweden agreement shipments of fuel and
other goods are not coming through in
accordance with the Sweden agreement the
port of had Ida
has come under the supervision of the UN
especially after the Houthis retreated
five kilometers in compliance with the
signed agreement for millions of Yemenis
like Hassan Ali and his friends what was
already a difficult life has become even
more challenging those who were once
able to feed themselves are now picking
through rubbish in the hopes of earning
a living hum Vata al-jazeera Sanaa